this morning barry sternlich one of the
most
famous well-respected investors in
america went on cnbc and andrew ross
sorkin asked him about bitcoin and gold
and so here is what barry said when he
was asked
the dichotomy though on the kathy woods
view which is that she's she believes
that there's going to be deflation at
the same time she's a proponent of
crypto
where are you right now we have a whole
screen of all the different
cryptocurrencies
effectively uh to you to your left
i own two of those
so um you know i for me and i think uh
novogratz has come on your show and
talked about it it's a diversification
and i think you know what jamie
yeah what jamie dimon talked about i
mean gold is kind of worthless too and
might silver i mean they have some
industrial uses but they're minor it's a
store of value and like the reason i own
bitcoin is because the us government and
and every government in the western
hemisphere is printing money now to the
end of time and this is a finite amount
of something and it's a it can be traded
globally and people have fiat currencies
whether it's in nigeria i'm not picking
on nigeria i have no idea if they have a
fiat currency or you know bolivia or
wherever you can move into something
that probably has that the world is
accepted as a substitute for gold and
since it's uh 18 million float or
something like that of 21 you know i
think bitcoin is it's the biggest it may
not be the one it's a dumb coin it has
no real purpose uh other than a store of
value and it's a little crazily volatile
so ether which is right below it i own
some of that that's a programmable
bitcoin and then there are tons of other
coins that are built off of that system
and and as as larry also mentioned i've
i've become very
interested in the blockchain technology
as a whole in the digital ledger which
is going to change
everything it's just we're probably
needing one of the internet and i don't
know when the internet started 1990 hey
pretty damn cool when you see this
basically the two big takeaways i have
from uh watching this is that one we
obviously are watching uh a bunch of
investors who are not known to be
bitcoin or crypto investors they don't
come out of that world these are legacy
investors who now are starting to
understand the value proposition of it
and what's really important is they've
already invested they've allocated
capital to the asset then on top of that
they now feel comfortable enough that
they understand what the value
proposition is why it will either go up
or down in value how they're going to
construct their portfolio around it and
when they have that confidence they then
are willing to talk about it publicly so
very very important to understand that
if somebody is just learning about it
they either have an investor they won't
talk about it publicly once they
actually understand it they usually will
invest their own money first then
they'll be willing to publicly talk
about it so when you see somebody on
television publicly talking about it
they've already done a lot of work
they've put in the time and effort they
understand it they've allocated capital
they have skin in the game and then they
go and they talk about it so that is
kind of one big takeaway the second big
takeaway was explicitly the comment that
the central banks in the western
hemisphere are going to keep printing
till the end of time that is the model
that we are currently in there is a
point of no return they're stuck i feel
for them there's nothing else they can
do they have to continue to intervene in
markets they have outlawed bear markets
they have banned market corrections and
they will continue to devalue the
currency at whatever rate they need to
that is the world that we live in and so
if that is going to continue then
investors are going to find other places
to go and put their wealth we've seen
folks like ray dalio talk about cash's
trash we now see uh barry sterling
talking about the fact they're going to
continue to print until the end of time
and so he explicitly talks about bitcoin
having that finite supply and going
ahead and allocating to it now when you
start to think of other investors what
is really interesting about barry is
barry is a lot of real estate and he's
very well known for hotels he's invested
in etc and so you can think about 21
million bitcoin almost in a way of
digital real estate that you can go and
actually have the dollar continued to be
devalued and so the asset that you hold
will continue to go up in u.s dollar
terms that is true of stocks that is
true of real estate that is true of
commodities and of bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies so over long periods of
time the devaluation of the currency
drives asset prices up that's why we see
that top 10 percent continue to get
richer and richer and richer they hold
majority of their uh net worth in assets
now what is also interesting about this
is that what we saw between october of
2020 when bitcoin was around 10 000
until march of 2021 we saw bitcoin go
from 10 to 64 000
a lot of that was people front running
inflation the thing about inflation that
is really important is that whether it
actually ever showed up or not didn't
nearly matter as much as the fact that
people thought inflation was coming if
you understand how inflation works and
you think that there will be high
inflation you try to move your assets
before the inflation comes you try to
get into an inflation hedge asset be
prepared it's kind of like when a
hurricane is coming what do you do you
don't wait for the hurricane to be there
in the middle like oh i gotta go to the
store to get milk and bread no you go
and you get it before the hurricane is
supposed to get there so that you are
prepared same thing with capital flows
and so in october and november and then
into the beginning of 2021 people
thought there would be high levels of
inflation coming and they pushed into
inflation hedge assets bitcoin has gone
up over 400 over the last year gold is
down about eight or nine percent people
quite literally dropped gold the market
cap contracted and they bought bitcoin
as an inflation hedge it has served as
the best inflation hedge out of all of
the inflation hedges that were available
and so if people think that inflation is
going to continue to persist those that
already allocated to the inflation hedge
asset they will likely continue to
allocate more and more and then those
who missed the opportunity they now wake
up and say oh wait a second i should
actually allocate more we see this in
the on-chain metrics the people who hold
bitcoin 85 of bitcoin has not moved in
the last 90 days and there continues to
be more and more people trying to buy
and that is why we have seen since the
summer bitcoin go from 30 000 to about
55 57 000 is there's more buyers than
sellers and people are looking trying to
get their hands on a global store of
value that can't be controlled by anyone
and can't be created out of thin air
john what do you think about this
inflation is obviously here it's not
going anywhere um i think people need to
do their research on what they think is
a good inflation hedge whether that's a
traditional thing like gold real estate
or kind of these newer assets like
cryptocurrencies and i think they need
to allocate their money accordingly how
they see fit right everyone's in a
different position but a lot of people
um
are getting hurt by inflation it's not
going anywhere and then we we've seen
over time a lot of really smart uh
investors have been more and more
allocating parts of their portfolio some
of their businesses into crypto um and
into bitcoin specifically and i think
that's really good because it just it
brings more um
validity to the space and more and more
people are kind of getting involved and
i haven't seen anyone that was involved
in bitcoin or involved in a lot of
cryptocurrency kind of take the step
back and actually remove it uh people
are more pressing the gas pedal i
thought barry was a boss on tv this
morning he is a boss he he rolled up he
had his shirt half unbuttoned
60 year old said gold is worthless
he said there's no utility he said i own
both of the i owned two of those and
then he was like alright i own bitcoin
in ethereum
he like tried to get cool he does not
own dogecoin for the people in the
comments
one time anthony and i met barry at a
pool party and he was wearing sunglasses
looking really cool um and i i obviously
didn't recognize him because i wasn't
expecting barry and
we left and i told the anthony i was
like that guy really knew a lot about
like miami real estate he was very
tanned and he was like paulina
he's got an investment firm that has a
hundred billion dollars
so jamie dimon said that bitcoin is
worthless and barry sterling said that
gold is worthless i tend to think barry
is going to be more right than uh than
jaime right do we agree with that yes
yeah i think that's like a kind of a
no-brainer i mean jamie's already been
proven wrong
so yeah one o'berry